Oh, hello.
I'm Gav.
I'm Dan.
We're The Slow Mo Guys.
And once again,
it's June.
I thought we'd done every iteration
of giant balloon possible.
You thought we had.
I had come up with a lot of other ideas
that potentially were
very expensive to make.
Or dangerous.
Or very dangerous.
But, we do have that probe lens
that we've used a couple of times.
And it's waterproof.
So what do you wanna do?
You wanna stick the probe
lens into the balloon?
I wanna probe the balloon.
And inside the balloon,
I want a load of water,
and one Daniel Gruchy.
So I have to like, live in the balloon?
Yeah, we have to sort of design a way
for you to stay inside
there for longer than, what?
30 seconds I think is your
total dive time in balloons.
I mean it was before yeah.
So I'm gonna have like a snorkel
and stuff ready to go in.
Yeah, and I thought that
the best one for this
because we want as much light
penetrating the balloon as possible,
be to either use a white
balloon or a clear balloon.
And thankfully, we did
buy a giant clear balloon.
This one?
About three years ago.
Yeah it's like, is it?
It's completely melted together somehow.
And honestly the Texas
summers of my garage
have not been kind to this one.
Yeah.
Well we've got another replacement one.
We a spare.
Sun's a little bit in and out today,
so we've got a light.
Dan's just setting it up.
Also bagged the entire phantom.
All right, Dan explain
how you're gonna breathe
once you're in the balloon.
Essentially, with great difficulty.
Because obviously, to
get around the problem
of not being able to breathe underwater
I'm gonna have to get into the balloon
with this scuba getup.
This is basically a scuba mask
with a dishwasher waste pipe
attached to the top of it,
secured with gaffer tape.
Yep, as you do.
Very, very secure.
The good thing about it
is, it has a rubber end.
So it sort of attaches
hopefully with a good seal.
Got a slight sound side effect as well.
If you ever stop hearing that noise,
it's because I'm drowning and
you need to pop it, all right?
Okay.
Whoa!
Oh.
Is it nice and cool?
It's pretty cool.
I don't know how you're
gonna do it like this,
through the side.
Sideways.
Bloody exposure's going nuts.
It looks likes you're putting
on some mental trousers.
Now you're like a genie that rolled over.
Fell over and couldn't get up again.
Yeah the lamp fell over.
He's going for it, he's committed.
Choking me windpipe.
And then once I'm scubaed
in, just like hold it tight.
And then you're gonna
have to get the hose,
and I can hold it with my hand, tight.
It's weird getting instructions
from someone who looks
like a ping pong bat.
Can you imagine if Google
Earth just happened
to fly over right now?
It'd end up in one of the newspapers.
Funny, like what has this
thing that's been seen?
Is it an alien of some sort?
Human hot water bottle spotted.
Yeah.
Can you talk to me through it?
This is not ideal.
What happens if the snorkel
falls out and I start drowning?
Just pop it.
How?
Have a screwdriver ready or something.
All right.
I'm giving you this.
What is it?
It's a snapped coat hanger.
What?
Well it will float and
if you keep your hand
over that bit, it won't
pop anything by accident.
What?
It's sharp, look.
Yeah but.
Quick, quick, quick, give it to me.
Give it to me.
You are rubbish.
Give it to me, give it
to me, give it to me.
I can't get it in now.
That is not, why did
you come up with that?
We need the hole here.
Okay you're gonna have
to push me from the back
of my neck to secure the water, that's it.
Push it.
Push the balloon, push it forwards.
Push the balloon with weight, forwards.
Push the balloon.
If you keep saying the same thing
it's just gonna crack me up.
All right let's do it.
And what if you get in there
and you're snorkel has popped out?
You're gonna put it in
and blow the water out?
I can try.
Okay.
Can't breathe.
Aha!
I couldn't!
You knew that it's filled with water.
You gotta blow it out.
No!
What it is, I've just realized.
Look.
There's like an air gap there,
you see that?
Well, yeah.
I didn't realize that was a thing.
So we have to pull the top off.
Okay it's day two.
New balloon.
Got some better
waterproofing on the phantom.
Just a splash bag, really.
And we've rectified the
slight breathing issue.
The slight breathing issue,
as in it actually works now.
'Bout that time, ay chap?
I think so.
The fact that it's sort
of white and transparent,
it looks way worse around
your leg right now.
It's like a weird twerk.
Did I put on some extra
pounds since yesterday?
I don't really understand.
What did you have for dinner last night?
Quesadillas.
Queso.
Yep, might be it.
Get some real James
Buckley vibes from this.
Okay?
It was in the water.
I think this video's gonna make
people really uncomfortable.
I really think so too.
I've already getting
sort of breathing anxiety
just watching you do this.
You're telling me.
I said to you, because
there's a big puddle here,
that you've got to keep my breathing hose
above the water line.
And what do you, like half
attach it to a cardboard box.
It's literally me breathing
and you half-assed it.
I phoned it in a little bit.
You did.
But I'd say that's the Slow Mo Guys' way.
Come on.
That's your lifeline.
If I die because my breathing
hose becomes unattached
from the cardboard box you've
used to put in the water,
I would not be best pleased.
It's all right.
I think it'll be safe.
I'll keep an eye on the box.
All right, all right.
No way.
Can you still hear, can you still breathe?
Uh-huh.
All right.
So I'm gonna just tie it off now.
This is one of the strangest
things I've ever done.
And I'm sure at the same time,
this is one of the strangest
things you've ever done.
Uh-huh.
Okay.
How well can you hear me?
Not very well.
What if I talk right here, B?
Oh, yeah.
Okay.
I am going to insert the device.
I can't see anything.
What am I looking at?
That's amazing.
I can see you.
All right, I guess don't cover your face,
and pop it somewhere behind your head.
It's sunny right now,
if you wanna go for it.
Okay, three, two, one.
How was that?
Oh my lord.
That was ridiculous.
An experience.
That was one of the most silly things
I've ever done.
Here we are.
Whoa!
You can totally see the
split there as well.
Yeah.
Look at that, whoa!
So if you're wondering why
it's actually very dark,
it's because the widest
aperture on this lens is an F14.
Which is many stops underexposed,
but that's all we can get
with this lens.
There's not really another lens
I have I can dunk in the water.
I mean that is pretty awesome,
but I did actually just cover my face.
Yeah, when I said pop it,
I said, you know, try to do
it without covering your face.
Look all right,
there's so many things
on my mind at that point.
Like, not drowning.
Not drowning, breathing.
Continuing to live.
I wish I was filming at just normal speed
when I came into the balloon.
'Cause I went in and I focused up
and I couldn't see anything
and then I just saw you like
a baby in a womb like this.
Also, when it popped, 'cause I had my lens
through the ring of the balloon,
the immediate release of stress
on the rest of the balloon
just made the hole go like that.
So my camera was like wha!
So I wasn't expecting that,
which I should've been.
I tell you what, let's try it again.
You compensate more for
the balloon popping.
And I won't cover my idiot face.
Okay so now we're switching
to a blue balloon,
because we've run out of
clear ones, unfortunately.
And it was already kind
of dark in the clear one
so I think because the blue
is going to be filtering
out all wavelengths of light except blue,
we're gonna have even
less light than before.
So what I'm gonna do is,
instead of decreasing the
frame rate to make it brighter,
I'm just going to
increase the shutter speed
from a 180 degree to a 360 degree.
I don't usually do it
because it makes a load of motion blur.
But we really need the stops.
Without seeing the balloon,
this is a weird sight.
Oh were you just filming me?
For goodness sake!
Could do with a hand.
Oh no, I'm stuck.
Fully stuck.
Oh god, it's still leaking out.
This has got to be like
a fetish for some people.
Gonna film as I come in.
Yep.
Ugh.
Ready?
Yep.
Ah, my ears!
God!
Oh the camera's burning me.
Oh what's burning you?
The camera.
Oh my goodness me.
Bloody.
Third-degree burn on my hand.
Look at the red.
Oh my god.
Put your hand up here.
You put your hand up here.
And I was doing this, to hold it, right?
Yeah.
I'll do that.
Oh, oh no!
How did you do that?
I would have to let go.
I didn't, I burned myself.
Ah, my ass is hot on this tripod.
Everything's black.
Everything that is black is really hot.
Playing back.
Ah, you can see me there.
Yep.
Really see me.
I really like the way this
one popped a lot more.
So I popped it like,
behind my left ear I think.
Whoa!
Look at that.
Wow.
And then immediately,
I was out of the water.
You were out of the water.,
You can see it immediately.
Whoa, that looks like a tidal wave.
It does.
It looks like an actual wave.
Like you've just been filming in a wave.
It looks like a titan waking up.
Yeah.
I like the water all splashing
away from the thing as well.
You did a much better job
of holding the camera there.
Yeah, it really made the
difference, didn't it?
Yeah.
Even though you got burned.
Totally worth it.
Yeah that was good, I like that one.
And I'm glad we didn't
go down in frame rate.
I'm glad we kept 1000.
It's a blurry 1000 but.
I think it still looks great.
I think we need that speed.
'Cause it's still only a couple of frames
where you're sort of in
there and it's ripped.
So I think that last one was great.
You didn't cover your face.
It looked amazing.
But we still have this gammy old one
that's all stuck to itself.
And I kinda want to see if it works.
I took it in the bath
and I sort of gave it a good talking to
and hopefully, it's gonna
actually be all right.
Oh.
What?
Yeah I don't think this one
that was all stuck to
itself is gonna work.
I mean we were just recording there
and I heard like a
trickling sound behind me.
I was like, "what's going on?"
Pretty laminar flow there, look at that.
It is nice and laminar.
Look at that.
You got any flex tape?
Flex tape?
What type of tape is that?
Aw, B.
You don't get any of my jokes.
Flex tape.
Yeah that's a lot of damage.
I've heard "that's a
lot of damage" before.
But I don't know what it's from.
Sorry.
It's all right.
To be fair, you applied it like flex tape.
I mean I'm really, really
just plastering sorta.
Oh there's another hole.
This is gonna be mostly tape.
I'm gonna be inside tape at this point.
We don't even know about holes underneath.
Oh, but the hole underneath don't matter.
Maybe if we just move this, to underneath.
As Snoop Dogg once said,
is this what white people do?
Is this, what white people do?
Yes it is.
This balloon was made
when Obama was president.
Get in there!
Get in there, bro!
There's a leaf in there.
Ow, my nose!
Ow, you're bloody killing me this time.
Do it from the back first.
Sorry, mate.
Ugh, what are you doing?
What are you doing?
The leaf, take the leaf out!
Take it out!
"There's a leaf in there,"
proceeds to not remove it.
It's hard to put,
it's like trying to put
a tie on someone else.
It's actually harder.
You just never get used to doing this.
This has never felt like
second nature to me.
Is that "Ace Ventura" backwards?
I'll just take my mask off, shall I?
Yeah that's a good idea.
Yep!
Ah, so much water got up my nose.
You could actually put
me through an igloo.
Ah-choo!
Bless you.
Aw yeah it's wicked.
It still absolutely flopped me down.
It was like extra whiplash that time.
Super powerful whiplash that time.
See it all draining away from the inside?
Yeah, so sick.
I'm impressed with how
quickly the lens clears.
It's got like a hydrophobic
coating on the front
by the looks of it.
'Cause it just immediately is gone.
It's crazy, isn't it?
You see perfectly well.
It's also such a small lens though.
Yeah.
It's sorta scary to get wet.
And that light, once it's popped,
gives some nice reflection too,
like this is a lovely backdrop.
I wonder if the focus changes
when the water goes away.
It must do.
Like the refraction means I'm
focused in a different place.
Wow I can't believe we got that done.
We usually have absolutely no crew
for all of our normal videos.
You know, YouTube Originals aside.
And we absolutely
could've used crew today.
That was a lot of work for two people.
There was so much going
on at the same time.
It's a lot to think about.
A lot of logistics.
With having someone
underwater in a balloon
and shoving a camera into it.
And honestly, once you're
inside the balloon,
I actually felt a bit alone.
Like I had to do everything.
I was like doing all the lights
and like feeding the air hose
and the water pipe and the lens
and trying to tie it off
and reaching my hand into a 90 degree bag.
Was it hard to hear what I was saying?
No, it was pretty easy to understand you.
Really?
Yeah.
I couldn't really hear you
unless you stood right next to the bag,
it was like quite difficult.
The worst thing is that
the phantom was in a black,
unventilated bag, which thankfully,
they're very rugged
cameras and can survive,
but my skin did not
survive holding the handle
for extended periods.
Hey, I'm impressed with you.
You committed.
You got burned.
You physically were burning yourself.
Like holding the camera.
Well, we've successfully done
another giant balloon June video.
I hope you enjoyed it.
Feel free to leave an idea in the comments
for what we should do next June.
And make sure you
subscribe, ring the bell,
and all that, second channel.
We'll see you very soon.
Can't believe we did with
a busted-ass balloon.
It had four holes in it.
I know, I was like jokingly taping it up.
And then I ended up
getting in it and doing it.
Uh, I'm exhausted.
Yeah, me too.
My legs are like shaking.
I almost got cramped in there.
I was like, "oh god no"
because I popped the balloon.
Yeah.
Should we play earlier?
Yeah let's go.